Rudy Guiliani flubs his landing we
examine the midterm races and the
President of the United States goes
after 3d gun printing and the Koch
brothers I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
one of the beautiful things about living
in the Donald Trump news cycle is that
every morning the president begins the
news cycle anew so I do show prep a lot
the night before and then I wake up in
the morning and it's an entirely new
show prep which is really exciting
because that means there's a lot to talk
about and a lot to do we'll get to all
of that in just a second first let's
talk about your second Amendment rights
this ends tonight my friends the u.s.
CCA are giving you five free chances to
win 1776 bucks in their great American
giveaway you can spend it on whatever
you want new gun extra ammo whatever but
it all ends at midnight tonight so
here's what I want you to do right now
take out your smartphone get on your
computer type in defend your family now
calm let's defend your family now calm
you can do it in seconds the official
rules are on the page and you will
instantly get five chances to win 1776
dollars that is 1776 bucks just for
clicking a few buttons it's free money
folks
don't just leave it on the table it's
part of a great cause defending your
second Amendment rights that's what the
US ECA does they protect responsible gun
owners like us this is indeed your last
chance so go check it out five free
chances to win just waiting for you
defend your family now calm go win right
now it's that easy defend your family
now calm and again the u.s. CCA provides
all sorts of wonderful educational
services legal services in case god
forbid you actually have to shoot at
somebody because somebody's in your
house or something the u.s. ECA makes
sure that you have all the legal
resources necessary go check them out
right now defend your family now calm
and get those five opportunities to win
1776 bucks towards guns and ammo go
check it out right now also I just want
to remind you you've heard I know that
we're taking the Ben Shapiro show live
this August to audiences in Dallas in
Phoenix but you should know we're now
two weeks away from those events and we
were almost entirely sold out so if you
haven't gotten your tickets yet they
pretty much have to do it now or you're
gonna miss it entirely and then you're
just gonna be sad right you're gonna be
sitting around weeping to yourself
thinking why God why what's your own
fault it's your own fault if you can go
to Daley wire calm slash events and buy
a ticket right now we're gonna party it
up in Dallas in Phoenix and if you're
not there well you snooze you lose gang
that's the way that it works okay so on
to today's news the President of the
United States were speaking about gun
rights the President of the United
States has now come out with a bizarre
tweet in which he attacks
3d gun printing now listen the president
does a lot of very good things on policy
and then he says a lot of stuff on
Twitter as I've said before the
president is fond of the saying of the
things well the president decided to go
on Twitter and sound off about 3d gun
printing this morning based
on essentially no knowledge of 3d gun
printing and so here's what he tweeted
out I am looking into 3d plastic guns
being sold to the public already spoke
to the NRA doesn't seem to make much
sense that's not what 3d gun printing is
okay like that seriously like if you
think the 3d gun printing is John
Malkovich and in the line of fire making
plastic guns in his basement that's not
what 3d gun printing actually is Steven
Gutowski of the Washington free beacon
points out that it is easy and legal to
find gun blueprints online and it should
be because otherwise you have to crack
down on the internet you have to crack
down on people's use of the Internet to
put out blueprints for guns that's
that's silly
it's ineffective it doesn't work and
Gutowski also points out the vast
majority of 3d printed gun designs are
not undetectable to metal detectors
because that's actually illegal it's
actually illegal the ban on the creation
of such weapons was extended to 2023
under the undetectable firearms acts
you're not allowed to actually
manufacture a plastic gun that can move
through a metal detector that is illegal
under federal law also 3d printed guns
are made of metal okay they're they're
actually made of metal the vast majority
of them it's just a 3d printer that uses
metal in order to carve out the parts in
the vast majority of people who are
using gun blueprints online to build
their guns are buying the constituent
parts from gun manufacturers in the
first place it's not like they're
sitting around and spending a hundred
thousand dollars on a 3d printer which
is what a good 3d printer costs why in
the world would you go and get all the
materials for a 3d printer to make an
ar-15 in your basement
it'll cost you 150 grand or you could
just go on down to your local gun dealer
and buy one for 1,500 bucks why exactly
would you do any of that the media put
out all this infamous information on the
threat of 3d guns people sitting in
their basements putting together these
guns by getting their their HP LaserJet
printer from 1997 and then printing out
a bunch of guns they put together and go
assassinate people that's not the way
any of this works also 3d guns are
notoriously unreliable to this point
they break down easily they're very
expensive to produce they're not nearly
as accurate as manufactured weapons you
can't fire them all that many times
before they start to fall apart in laws
the Templeton crackdown on this stuff
are our foolhardy but this is why the
president shouldn't be tweeting about
these issues because all it does is
create blood in the water for a gun
control Democrat speaking of which
talking abut in the water for Democrats
the president has attacked now the Koch
the reason he's attacking the Koch
brothers is because the Koch brothers do
not like his tariffs so the Koch
brothers for those who don't know are
these these brothers who run Koch
Industries which is essentially a I
believe a natural gas and oil industry
and and the Koch brothers are worth
something on the order of 80 billion
dollars there were some enormous amount
of money and they've used a lot of this
money to promote various causes
political and non-political they give
money to a variety of charities they're
libertarian and orientations they're not
social conservatives they are very Pro
free trade and they're very Pro
immigration and this is just how they've
been for 30 years well they came out the
other day and they sort of said that
president Trump's tariff policy is bad
which is correct his tariff policy
generally is bad unless he is using it
to ratchet down tariffs with the rest of
the world so far it seems like some of
that has happened but the president has
this bizarre love for tariffs that don't
make a lot of sense so the Koch brothers
said they're not going to support a
particular candidate Trump wants them to
support so he tweeted this out the
globalist Koch brothers who have become
a total joke in real Republican circles
are against strong borders and powerful
trade number one I don't know what
powerful trade is that's not a term that
means anything free trade is a thing and
fair trade doesn't mean anything
powerful trade certainly doesn't mean
anything and but he continues I never
sought their support because I don't
need their money or bad ideas they love
my tax and regulation cuts judicial pics
and more okay so the more are you
ripping on them and then he continues by
saying I made them richer their network
is highly overrated i beaten them at
every turn they want to protect our
companies outside the US from being tax
time for America first and the American
worker a puppet for no one two nice guys
with bad ideas make America great again
so he's attacking and the Koch brothers
listen the president can attack whomever
he wants and this is a good populist
line Bernie Sanders has spent the better
part of several years attacking the Koch
brothers the Democrats have turned the
Koch brothers into this evil nefarious
shadow Enterprise the truth is the Koch
brothers have supported Republicans by
and large and they've supported
free-market Republicans by and large the
Koch brothers are not the enemies here
and it's not the Koch brothers that are
inhibiting from trade agenda it's the
market itself the reality is Trump's
trade agenda is not particularly good
now it was interesting I was on Laura
Ingraham show last night
and Laura's much more of a trade
restriction Asst img' brought this up
and she was suggesting that it's Trump's
trade policy that makes him so popular
in places like Michigan and Ohio and
Wisconsin and pencil
I don't actually think that's the case I
think the President Trump sounds an
awful bad tariff sounds like he's Pro
manufacturing and so a lot of people
resonate to that yeah on a sort of
emotional level but the truth is that
Trump's tariff policy has actually hurt
a lot of these manufacturing centers a
lot more than its help these
manufacturing centers because a lot of
the companies that manufactured things
have to use imports as inputs they're
importing steel from the EU or from
Canada and then they're using that in
their production of trucks or they have
parts that are coming in from China and
they're using that in the production of
their final product and tariffs hurt
those companies what the president is
very good at is expressing sympathy for
these folks who are losing their jobs I
do think that there's a cultural battle
that the president has engaged in in
which he's very good I think he has an
innate sympathy for people who do
blue-collar work in the Rust Belt in a
way that Democrats do not the Democrats
as I talked about on the show a few
weeks ago have a lot of 1/8 sympathy for
the New York Daily News reporters who
are being laid off they think those jobs
are deeply deeply important but the
factory worker in Ohio they don't really
care too much about that guy the truth
is that we should care an equivalent
amount about all of these jobs I don't
think the manufacturing job in Ohio is
necessarily worth more than a reporting
job in New York but the other way around
is true also I don't think a New York
reporting job is any more important than
a manufacturing job out there in Ohio a
job is worth what the job is worth that
said we ought to be easing the pain of
people who live in those areas and are
seeing their industries left behind
that's why job retraining is good that's
why folks like Mike Rowe have millions
of dollars that they've placed into job
retraining programs in order to create
skill sets for people who are moving out
of industries that are falling apart and
being out competed but only in tariff
policies the best solution for that the
president is attacking the Koch brothers
I'm not sure how that is politically
effective and this is why the sort of
circular firing squad that the president
sometimes engages in is not particularly
a bright move I just don't think that's
particularly smart speaking of not
particularly smart the president on
Twitter like really if the president
just didn't tweet you know how popular
he'd be right now I know there are a lot
of people in Trump's support base who
believe that what makes from popular is
his Twitter and I think with some folks
in the base that's true they feel like
Trump is fighting he's out there
fighting for them and he can sense what
he wants and how he feels because he's
constantly tweeting things so for those
thirty five percent of people thirty
thirty percent of Americans great but
what about the other 70% of Americans
here's the thing I think if Trump stop
tweeting all those people who are
already sympathetic to Trump are still
gonna be sympathetic to Trump and I
think that his tendency to run on at the
tweet is not going to hurt him with with
people in the middle if he stops doing
it so much right the diarrhea of the
Twitter is not helpful to him with
people who are in the middle of the
country or in the middle of the
political spectrum it's just not useful
an example of this so the president this
morning not only does he go off on three
D guns again wrong or go off on the Koch
brothers again I think overstated and
wrong even if I disagree with the Koch
brothers on some of their immigration
policy not only that the president
sounds it off on collusion now as we
mentioned yesterday on the show Rudy
Giuliani hath not a Giuliani eyes but it
read Giuliani yesterday he was speaking
on CNN and he talks about how collusion
was not a crime and I said yesterday
this is not a smart legal strategy it is
just not smart to go out there talking
about how collusion is not a crime in
the middle of you making the case that
the president didn't engage in collusion
in the first place and then Giuliani
botched it even worse yesterday he went
on Fox News to try and explain himself
and he made things significantly worse
by hinting at the possibility of a
second meeting within the Trump campaign
about the meeting between Donald Trump
jr. and Natalia Veselin lanskaya the
Russian connected lawyer who was
supposedly going to present Clinton Oppo
research to the Trump campaign Giuliani
called in to Fox News and then he
proceeded to just bash things
dramatically here was Giuliani talking
to the ladies of outnumbered it did not
go well there are two different meetings
one of which has leaked out the other of
which has been given to three reporters
in je Seco and I have been successful I
think I'm beating it back there wasn't
another meeting that has been leaked but
hasn't been in public yet okay that was
a meeting an alleged meeting three days
before
according to calling according to the
leak maybe cold over the druthers I
don't know they haven't pursued it and
the two publications they're not going
to publish it I think they found
independent contradiction okay so here's
what Giuliani I think is trying to say
is that there was the meeting in Trump
Tower between Donald Trump jr. and Jared
Kushner and a bunch of members of the
Trump campaign and this Russian
connected lawyer and now that those
meeting number one and now Giuliani is
sort of letting it slip on Fox and
is that there's an accusation there was
a second meeting three days before about
this primary meeting well we didn't know
about that until Giuliani went on
national TV and talked about it and then
he said well that meeting didn't happen
so then why are you talking about that
meeting like we didn't know about it
until you just said it one second ago so
I don't know why Rudy Giuliani is doing
this I don't know whether he's just
confused about the issues I don't know
whether he has coined his own version of
law this is not good defense strategy
it's not good legal defense strategy the
problem is the president sort of bought
into it and mirrored that on Twitter
today I will explain in just a second
first let's talk about your sleep okay
the fact is that your sleep quality is
not as good as it could be and the
reason is because it's something you
never think about your sheets okay you
never think about your sheets you think
about the quality if your mattress maybe
you think about your pillow you think
about the temperature in the room they
never think about your sheets you just
bought those things for like thirty five
bucks at the local retail outlet well
they're not good okay you're sleeping on
a tarp you need to stop sleeping on a
tarp you need to go get yourself a nice
set of sheets you're really going to
enjoy and that's what Boleyn branch does
okay they make bedding it and blankets
is made from pure 100% organic cotton
which means it starts out super soft and
then gets even softer over time you can
buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets cost up to a thousand
bucks in the store but when branch eats
are only a couple of hundred bucks
it may sound expensive it really isn't
considering you're sleeping on them
every single night Boleyn brand sheets
are so good that my wife and I got some
we actually took out all of our other
sheets and we threw them away because
the other ones just you can't sleep on
them after you've slept on the quality
of Bowland branch everybody who tries
Boleyn branch loves them which is why
shipping is free and you can try them
for 30 nights if you don't love them
send them back for a refund but you're
not gonna want to because they are that
good check them out right now my
listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bowl and branch comm
promoter Ben that's bull and branch calm
promo code bad use that promo Club Ben
you get $50 off that's bol oh and branch
comp promo Club been the best set of
sheets that you can buy on the market
today bull and branch comm promo code
Ben for 50 bucks off okay so Giuliani
doing yeoman's work to confuse everyone
about the situation regarding regarding
the Trump Tower meeting and then
Giuliani follows that one up by saying
listen we don't have to cooperate with
Robert Muller we're going to obstruct
but we're not going to cooperate with
our tomorrow he says this yesterday and
Fox News I thank John for all the
cooperation he gave them because he puts
us in a position where we don't have to
cooperate given some of the revelations
in the last
for weeks we've been driven further away
from the idea of answering any questions
from them we don't think they have a
legitimate investigation okay so we're
not gonna answer any questions now if
you want to look innocent this is
probably not the smartest way to do it
and then Trump decides to double down on
Giuliani's strategy so Trump tweets this
out today he tweets out collusion is not
a crime but that doesn't matter because
there was no collusion except by crooked
Hillary and the Democrats okay that
tweet is slightly confusing for a couple
of reasons first of all he is correct
the collusion is not a crime however
collusion is not an illegal term
conspiracy is a crime if it turns out
that the Trump campaign was coordinating
with the Russians to affect the election
that's probably a campaign finance
violations violation of federal law
obstruction is a crime if you decided to
lie to the FBI that's a crime if Donald
Trump jr. did that and then Trump says
that doesn't matter there was no
collusion okay could have just said
there's no collusion in the first place
which is your strongest case right if
somebody says Shapiro you commit a tax
evasion I said tax evasion isn't a crime
and also I didn't do it it's you'd be
kind of confused right and I think that
this is just a not good PR listen I
actually sort of believe Trump at least
so far because I don't see the evidence
that he was involved in any sort of
campaign collusion that he knew about
coordination with the Russians or that
he himself was coordinating with the
Russians or even that the campaign
actively coordinated with the Russians
other than you know wanting to I don't
see the actual evidence that they did so
but for Trump to say this sort of stuff
is not great and then for him to finish
up that tweet with Hillary colluded but
you just said collusion isn't a crime so
which is it earlier this week he
suggested that Hillary Clinton by the
way should be prosecuted for collusion
so you're gonna need to get your story
straight here except for the fact that I
think people have made up their mind on
the Moller investigation if you're a
Trump fan you think that it's a bunch of
crap if you're not a Trump fan you think
that Muller is gonna nail Trump to the
wall in the end does any of this really
damage Trump
probably not that's why we're gonna have
to wait to see you know what exactly
comes out from all of this I don't think
anything is going to come out but that's
why Trump would be better off just kind
of lowering the chaos level a little bit
that said you can see the Democrats
getting out over their skis they're very
eager for Trump to go down here Jonathan
Turley over on MSNBC he says that
essentially we are one witness away from
catastrophe here I think the Kohen
development is very serious I mean he's
one witness away from a potential
tast Rafi if any of those five witnesses
breaks and supports Michael Cohen this
is gonna get real bad real fast okay so
there's this hope on the left that
Michael Cohen is gonna take down
president Trump I don't think that's the
case but I do think it would behoove
president Trump to simply go at it again
I am a lawyer okay as a lawyer the first
rule of lowering is tell your client to
shut up
serious it's like the very first rule of
loitering even if you watch movies what
you see is the idiot client who tells
their lawyer I'm gonna talk to the
police I'm gonna say what I want to say
and the words like well if Rudy Giuliani
were doing his job right now he would be
saying to the president mr. president
stop just stop
like I'm I'm gonna make sure that you're
okay here but you really need to stop
with the tweeting because that's what
any lawyer worth his salt would be doing
I'm sort of surprised that Giuliani
hasn't done more of that frankly okay so
how is this having any impact on the
midterm elections let's talk about where
we stand just a few weeks away from the
midterm elections we are now entering
August we're about to enter August so
that leaves us oddest September October
and then we are at the elections we're
three months away from the midterm
elections and they do not look good
particularly good for Republicans right
now that's why I'm not in favor of this
sort of hear no evil see no evil speak
no evil strategy that so many
commentators are on the right we need to
look at the data I understand the polls
were not accurate with regard to
President Trump that does not mean you
shouldn't look at the warning signs and
think maybe the Republicans need to do
something a little bit better leading up
to the elections according to the New
York Times that this comprehensive look
at the battleground seats and here is
what Nate Cohen reports he says the
battleground in the fight for control of
the house is starting to come into focus
with 99 days to go until the November
election it's not exactly the
battleground that analysts expected it's
not dominated by well-educated suburban
districts that voted for Hillary Clinton
instead the battleground is broad and it
includes a long list of working-class
and rural districts that voted for
President Trump in 2016 the broader
battleground is a positive development
for Democrats it's a reflection of how
much the Republican structural advantage
in the house has eroded over the last
year while remains vut isn't helping the
Republicans as much as analysts assumed
it would be at least not yet so they
looked at the various districts that are
assumed to be competitive by cook
Political Report and what they're
finding is that white districts are
heavily Republican obviously black
districts are very heavily Democrat
Hispanic districts are very heavily
Democrat
districts with college graduates are
very heavily Democrat rural districts
are very heavily Democrat suburban
districts are heavily Republican so it's
that there is this this really
interesting divide the broader
battleground has also opened up a gap
between two common ways of thinking
about the midterms as Nate Cohen
national polls and historical voting
patterns suggest the Democrats are only
slight favourites to take the house well
early polls of individual districts
special election results and the ratings
of excellent prognosticators suggests
that the Democrats are in a stronger
position to this point we've mainly seen
polls of the generic congressional
ballot which asks voters whether they
intend to vote Democrat or Republican
Democrats have generally led on this
ballot by six to eight percentage points
over the last few months which is around
what analysts believe Democrats need to
have an even shot of retaking the
chamber the Republicans still have
structural advantages but there been a
flurry of Republican retirements which
has led to 42 open seats many of them
the sort of well trenched in entrenched
and incumbents in competitive districts
whose retirements are most valuable for
Democrats on paper that the Republicans
still have a big geographic advantage
they're only nine Republican held
districts that voted more favorably for
Democrats in the last two presidential
elections than the rest of the country
did but that advantage doesn't seem to
be helping the Republicans as much as it
has been in past presidential cycles
Democrats are putting conservative
districts into play because the overall
national political environment is more
favorable to Democrats than the generic
ballot polls imply it's also possible
that the districts presidential vote
choice will play a smaller than expected
role in determining how a district will
vote for the house which makes sense
there's been a very broad gap in 2010
and 2014 between the presidential year
ballots and the off year election
ballots a lot of that has to do with
enthusiasm Trump voters aren't going to
show up when Trump isn't on the ballot
there's a lot of enthusiasm among
Republicans for Trump himself is there
as much enthusiasm for their local
Congress people not necessarily and the
same thing is obviously true for
Democrats all the places where people
were really enthusiastic to get out
there for Hillary Clinton they're not
showing up either but that means that
the vote totals are reverting to a sort
of norm that you see in off-year
elections now when Democrats are in
charge that means that Republicans are
more fired up to go out and vote when
Republicans are in charge Democrats
presumably are more fired up to vote so
the most vulnerable Republican held
districts are only somewhat better
educated and somewhat more suburban than
the country as a whole
they're broadly representative of non
urban America they backed mr. Trump for
president about 31% of residents have a
college degree slightly more than the
national average but the sheer number of
competitive districts is important in
its own right on paper it would be
enough to make Democrats fare fairly
clear favorites if one assumes Democrats
do well in each category is the party
out of power has done in recent wave
elections this is what I've been
suggesting is that the the president's
you know kind of hot-button approach to
issues it could actually fire up the
Democrats it could be that the Democrats
are so upset with President Trump that
they go out and they vote in large
numbers in these congressional elections
and that could be a serious problem for
Republicans in in these election races
now again maybe all the polls are wrong
maybe Republicans somehow recover maybe
it doesn't end up being as bad as it
looks like it's going to be right now
but to sort of ignore the data I think
would be a fairly large mistake at this
point in time okay meanwhile we're gonna
talk about the President of the United
States and what he has to say about the
government shutdown because this is part
of his election strategy in just a
second first honestly about this really
really awesome service that I have found
it really is amazing when you shop
online do you turn into a tab holder
like here you open a bunch of tabs and
what you're trying to do is find the
best possible deal on a particular
product well instead what you need to
actually do is try a service called
honey it's a free browser add-on that
over nine million people are using every
single day to save money while they shop
online so with a couple of clicks you
can add honey to any browser for free
and then shop like you normally do so
how does it work well honey scans and
tests millions of coupons in the
background instead of you looking for a
coupon code and trying to find a coupon
code for various product
honey scans and tests millions of
coupons in the background and a check
out honey automatically applies the best
coupon so you're automatically saving
money just by using honey Time magazine
has called honey basically free money
over nine million people using it every
single day I use Amazon a lot honey
allows me to find the best deals on
Amazon
simply with the click of a button it
runs in the background it really is
amazing and the way they do this the way
honey works this is they basically have
deals with the folks who are selling
that they get a percentage of sales kind
of or I mean that's essentially the way
that they saved their money that's the
way they make their money so you save
money they save money and they get the
same sort of benefits that any coupon
provider would go check them out right
now there's no reason not to add honey
to your browser right now it is free it
takes two clicks to install and it'll
save you a lot of money get honey for
free adjoin honey calm slash Ben again
that's join honey calm slash Ben to
start saving with honey right now that's
join honey calm slash Ben there's no
reason not to save money I mean this is
this is no brainer frankly okay so
meanwhile the president is trying to gin
up the base with a lot of the
immigration talk the problem is that
it's not clear the president is
supremely credible when it comes to the
idea that he is going to hold fast on
the immigration issue so the president
yesterday said that he is willing to do
a government shutdown over the
immigration issue over wall funding but
he has no red line which means that he
really isn't willing to shut down the
government but he's sort of signaling
that he is so what exactly is this
supposed to mean no one really knows I
would be certainly willing to consider a
shutdown if we don't get proper border
security thank you please sir just to
follow up on that quickly is the 25
billion dollars the red line for you I
have no red line unlike President Obama
I just want great border security okay
so that that means nothing right if you
don't have a red line if there's no
point at what you're willing to say no
then you don't mean you're gonna veto a
bill that comes down that doesn't have
the border well funding and then folks
like Ann Coulter who have been stumping
for the wall this has been her chief
goal in life is to get President Trump
to build this wall this wall has not
been built and the President does have
to hold Congress's feet to the fire the
President does actually have to say to
Congress listen you send me a bill I
don't like I will veto it
so when Trump says listen I want that
border wall funding they say do you have
a red line on signing a bill and he says
no what he really means is that he's not
gonna veto anything and that's a sign of
weakness the hill is reporting right now
that President Trump has privately
agreed with congressional Republicans to
delay the fight over funding for his
border wall until after the November
midterm elections despite his public
statements expressing a willingness to
shut down the government over the issue
an administration official is telling
the Wall Street Journal the President
sees merit in having this battle after
the election the aide said so in other
words Trump is saying that he's willing
to do a government shutdown but he's not
really willing to do a government
shutdown now this is where Trump is at
odds with some congressional Republicans
like Mitch McConnell McConnell thinks
government shutdowns are always bad for
Republicans I don't agree I don't think
Mitch McConnell is right about this I
think that bad policy is bad for
Republicans I don't think that many
Americans care about government
shutdowns and I do have an ideological
problem with the Republicans who are so
frightened of government shutdowns on a
routine basis Oh No
they're gonna shut down the government
we're all going to die I thought you
were the party of limited government I
thought you were to the party that said
that the government was not the be-all
end-all and yet here we are suggesting
that it is the be-all end-all and if the
government shuts down everyone is going
to die and it's going to be the worst
thing that ever happened this is how you
end up with Republicans spending insane
insane amounts of money here right now
the Republicans have essentially racked
up more debt than the Democrats did at
the same time you know it's really crazy
like the Republicans just racked up I
think it was another what 1.3 3 trillion
dollars of debt yeah this is the party
that is supposed to be that is supposed
to be standing for fiscal responsibility
yeah it just it makes no sense to me if
you are going to shut down the
government now is the time to do it
because you're not gonna have the
Republican votes later if things keep
going the way they're going the
Republicans lose the house and they may
lose the Senate then you think you're
gonna have the ability to get Democrats
to play ball on this you're gonna go you
think I'm gonna wall funding from the
Democrats you think the Democrats are
actually gonna come forward with wall
funding they've said they they may be a
solid interest in preventing anything
from happening so that they can defeat
President Trump in 2020 there's a
limited window once we hit the election
of 2018 that wall funding is basically
gone if the Republicans lose the house
there will be no wall end of story it is
that simple
which means that you better make hay
while the Sun shines this is the reason
why Mitch McConnell is saying let's
confirm as many judges as humanly
possible right now because if we lose
the Senate we're basically toast and
anyone who's watching the stuff knows
the Democrats are not going to work with
Trump on any of this stuff but McConnell
is deeply afraid of the blowback anytime
there's any sort of government shutdown
he thinks that the American people
simply can't stomach it I think the
American people are a little tougher
than this Mitch McConnell is wrong here
here's the Senate Majority Leader saying
that the wall funding has to wait until
after the midterms is the funding of the
border wall going to wait until after
the midterm elections probably and
that's something we do have a
disagreement on and so Homeland Security
won't get funded before the midterm
probably not but most of the government
will be covered so you're not worried
about a government shutdown because
that's not gonna happen
okay so McConnell just assuring that
it'll never happen and Trump obviously
doesn't have the willingness to actually
go all the way to the wall for his own
preferred war policy if you're a Trump
voter who voted based on his immigration
policy you've got to be disappointed
with the president not pushing
Republicans hard enough now
is it McConnell's fault sure is it the
fault of people like Lisa Murkowski and
Susan Collins and the various sort of
moderate caucus of the Republicans in
the Senate absolutely but in the end
it's the President of the United States
who gets to decide what he signs and
what he doesn't remember it was
President Obama who shut down the
government in 2013 not the Republicans
who's Obama who said I will not sign a
bill that does not include funding for
Obamacare Ted Cruz said here's a bill no
funding for Obamacare and and Obama
simply said I'm not going to sign it and
that was that
and then the Republicans caved and they
made some sort of a deal with the
Democrats why exactly Trump can't do the
same thing or is unwilling to do the
same thing as beyond me why are
Republicans more afraid of government
shutdowns than Democrats why it grants
the Democrats the premise Democrats are
happy with government shutdowns because
they think that the government is
absolutely necessary and vital
Republicans should say listen we're not
going to pass a budget unless the budget
is good and then if we pass a bad budget
then we are wasting other people's money
we are racking up debt that we're never
going to repay if we shut down the
government and and there is no funding
for these these sort of various and
sundry items guess what the country
still continues to function we are
always warned that there will be zombie
apocalypses in the streets if a budget
doesn't pass and guess what it's
happened like four times in the last
five years four times in the last six
years you know many times there's been a
zombie apocalypse zero Barack Obama had
to manufacture crises during a
government shutdown in order for people
to even care nobody would have even
noticed except that Barack Obama decided
he was going to ban people from open
park memorials he's going to somehow
shut down the World War two monuments in
Washington DC so that veterans couldn't
visit it just as that people would feel
the pain who's gonna shut down national
parks for example there's no reason that
I think would be a good example to the
American public once in a while for
there to be a government shutdown which
doesn't result in the end of the world
in fact the Republicans are running away
from this is is just beyond me I don't
understand why they would do this I
don't understand why they think it's
gonna energize the base to continue
passing trillion dollar budget budget
packages that suck and are filled with
pork I mean the Republican Party when
they do this sort of stuff they look
like Democrats white they look like
Democrats like light except more gutless
just not good stuff any way around
meanwhile in breaking news the first
trial of special counsel Robert Muller's
Russia probe got underway on Tuesday
with poem anna fort a former chairman of
US president donald trump's 2016
campaign facing charge
that he had tens of millions of dollars
earned in Ukraine and offshore accounts
and defrauded banks for loans this
according to Reuters the tax and bank
fraud trial in a Virginia federal court
represents the first test of Muller's
ability to win a conviction of a former
Trump aide now recognized the mana for
indictment has nothing to do with
campaign 2016 it is just man afford
being prosecuted for his various and
sundry illegalities alleged illegalities
with regard to Ukraine years ago three
other aides including mana forts
longtime business partner Rick Gates
have already pled guilty and are
cooperating with mullahs probe
prosecutors are seeking to provide
details of mana forts work for a
pro-russian political party in Ukraine
raising the possibility that new
information about his Russian
connections could in fact emerge manna
fort has filed a motion to have the
details of that work excluded from the
trial again not clear that anything has
to do with President Trump poster
protesters are showing up trying to
suggest that mana Ford is going down
that will bring Trump down with him but
there's no evidence that that is
actually the case manna Fort works for
Trump for something like four months
honestly I don't think that Trump really
knew mana for I think that what happened
here is that no one who had a great
reputation was working for Team Trump
and so they simply went and they got the
the one guy who the the RNC recommended
mana form was very tied into the RNC and
so they went to the RNC they said who
should we get as a campaign manager they
said Paul mana Ford he hired Paul mana
for mana Ford ends up being corrupt a
fire ism I don't know why mana for it
has to be tied to Trump per se but the
Democrats are fully on board with the
idea that mana four is going to bring
down Trump again I think that is a lot
of wishful thinking on the part of the
Democrats okay I want to talk about
President Trump and Iran I also want to
talk about sports for a little while but
first we're gonna have to go over to
Daley we're calm and subscribe so go
ahead over there subscribe
daily we're calm $9.99 a month gets you
a subscription to our podcast Michael
Knowles's execrable podcast the Andrew
Clavin show go check all of that out
plus you got to be part of our mailbag
on Fridays and when you get the annual
subscription this the very greatest in
all beverage vessels the leftist year is
hot or cold tumblr it is indeed
fantastic go check it out right now
it's 99 bucks a year also subscribe to
YouTube please subscribe to iTunes go
check us out over there so that you can
be part of our Sunday special in fact I
think the do we have a clip from the
upcoming Sunday special with Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes do we have that clip that
we're going to try and have on
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes I think we have
a bit of a preview of that act
joy I think my strength is that I am
honest and I am authentic and I think
that even Republicans like write letters
to our campaign saying thank you if
corporations paid if we if we reverse
the the tax bill but when raised our
corporate tax rate to 28% which is not
even as high as it was before that's two
trillion dollars right there and then
the last key which is extremely
extremely important is reprioritization
[Music]
okay just just a quick note to quick
note to all of the folks on the left you
didn't understand that ally Stuckey's
parody of Alexandria Ocasio card houses
in fact a satire that's satire okay I
didn't actually interview Alexandria
kasnia Cortez just so you idiots don't
think that I'm making it up and that I
actually interviewed her and I'm taking
her out of context that's what we call
humor right there a little bit of humor
to spice up your deck okay so go check
this out
iTunes SoundCloud YouTube subscribe
Lewis review we always appreciate it
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
yeah everything is stupid and that
should be my slogan we need to have a
t-shirt that says but everything is
stupid
ben shapiro that's that's that's really
we need that t-shirt in the shapiro
store ASAP
over at amazon okay so meanwhile
speaking of everything is stupid
yesterday the president again speaking
out of turn on a topic of which he knows
very little he was asked about meeting
with iran with no preconditions now i
recall
literally a week ago one week ago the
president of the united states went on
twitter and he threatened iran with
all-out nuclear war in all caps which
was basically DEFCON two yesterday he
was asked whether he would meet with the
iranian leadership and here's what he
had to say i'm ready to meet any time
they want to and i don't do that from
strength or from weakness i think it's
an appropriate thing to do no
preconditions if they want to me tell me
no no okay in 2007 barack obama said he
would meet with the iranians without
preconditions and we all went nuts on
the right because that's a stupid idea
you don't meet with America's enemies
without preconditions now I know there
are a lot of you out there right now
you're saying but didn't president Trump
meet with kim jeong-hoon without
preconditions
yes i thought that was stupid as well
and guess what it turns out not to have
actually accomplished anything according
to the washington post multiple
intelligence officers have been
monitoring ongoing activity recently
from North Korea's nuclear and missile
testing facilities and what they find is
that North Korea is building new
possible intercontinental ballistic
missiles despite Kim Jong Un's
denuclearization agreement from his
summit with President Trump now I know
though it's the amazon washington post
don't believe them here's the thing i
don't actually believe that north korea
is going to disarm because kim jong-un
and donald trump are best friends who
are gonna go golfing now i don't think
that's how diplomacy works i think trump
is wrong when he thinks that you just
get into a room with a bad guy and then
you become friends and you have cigars
together and you go to a strip club and
then everybody's friends and then they
give up their nuclear weapons that's not
what happens here iran doesn't become
friendly just because you meet with them
this idea the interpersonal relationship
interpersonal relationships are the
basis on foreign policy they never have
been and this is not just a myth that is
promulgated by you know president Trump
or Obama it's a myth that was
promulgated on asleep been promulgated
for a long time if you go over to the
Reagan Library for example I love the
Reagan Library it's just fantastic and
Ronald Reagan great president but one of
the exhibits over at the Reagan Library
has this exhibit showing Ronald Reagan
with Mikhail Gorbachev and the idea is
that Ron
Dragan Mikhail Gorbachev really got
along and that's why the Soviet Union
collapsed that is not why the Soviet
Union collapsed the Soviet Union
collapsed because Mikhail Gorbachev
miscalculated he thought that the
Soviets could not continue their defense
build-up and so they had to loosen the
reins on the various satellite states
that made up the USSR those satellite
states then quickly broke off as fast as
possible and it was too late to stop the
momentum there's nothing that he could
do about it if you read the Russian
internal documents it is very clear
that's exactly what happened it was not
that Ronald Reagan got into a room and
and he and Mikhail Gorbachev had a cup
of coffee together and suddenly they're
our best friends Mikhail Gorbachev I was
like boom oh but get the communism great
idea that's not what happened ok so this
idea that Trump is gonna sit down with
Hassan rouhani who is a terrorist
supporting piece-of-crap and that
rouhani is suddenly gonna decide that
he's gonna give up his terroristic
program that's not what's going to
happen I don't like ideological
inconsistency and the fact that there
are so many people who are willing to
bend over backwards to make excuses for
this sort of stuff I find completely
ridiculous in in it's just it's
ridiculous to me it doesn't make a lot
of sense now I've been very critical of
the Obama of the Trump administration
today because President Trump was very
busy in saying things but then there's
what they actually do and this is the
part that's really hard for folks to
wrap their brains around they'll say
Shapiro you say so many things about the
president saying things that you don't
like but you're very supportive of the
administration right because what they
do and what they say are two completely
different things so for example they
have now launched a religious liberty
task force over at the Department of
Justice attorney General Jeff Sessions
announced that they would provide
religious liberty guidance central to
the new task force rooted in president
Trump's executive order from last year
directing agencies to respect and
protect religious liberty and political
speech the task force is going to be
co-chaired by associate attorney general
Jesse penuche Oh according to sessions
so he said that there have been a lot of
examples recently of religious Americans
being targeted nuns being ordered by
contraceptives US senators asking
judicial and executive branch nominees
about dogma and so we need a task force
to protect religious Americans yes we do
okay we have a civil rights task force
inside the DOJ it was used by the Obama
administration for various and sundry
political activities that were actually
not good protecting religious Americans
from the predations of local government
is a worthwhile thing protecting
religious Americans from discrimination
is a good thing
so the Trump administration continues to
do a lot of good things at the same time
that President Trump can
to say a lot of chaotic things and this
is why if the president could just
become a spokesperson for his own
policies I don't Lee I'm asking too much
here if you could just become a
spokesperson for his administration's
own policy for the freedoms that are
being promoted by this administration by
the for the economic record of this
administration Republicans would
actually have a better shot in 2018 this
religious liberty task force is a very
good thing and it's an area where
Democrats are extraordinarily extreme
it's an area where Democrats have been
proclaiming that you have to force
religious Baker's to bake that cake it's
an area where they have been suggesting
that religious people are bigots and
terrible folks president Trump has
fought back against that's who the nail
that's a wonderful wonderful thing why
don't we know about it why isn't the
president Sweeting about that he should
be the answer is he should be he's now
in a position to tweet about his great
record not just tweet about things that
don't really matter like the molar
investigation which I don't know is
actually going to end up being a thing
anyway you know the president has a good
story to tell if he is just willing to
tell it now speaking of people who don't
have a good story to tell I have to
comment on a guy named Cinque agar yeah
you may not know about Cinque agar
Cinque is a guy who runs something
called The Young Turks and I've debated
shang-chi ger on everything from health
care policy to mostly health care policy
but Cinque is is a very hardcore leftist
and he's very upset why is he upset
always upset with Tucker Carlson because
Tucker Carlson said the other day that
adult film stars are indecent which
seems to me definitional like that's
literally their job is to be indecent
their literal job is to take off their
clothes and have sex with people for
money on camera so I'm not seeing the
decent part of that Tucker Carlson said
it was indecent for Democrats to portray
stormy Daniels as a heroine when she had
enough one-night stand with a married
man and got paid a hundred and thirty
grand to shut up about it and then
decided to become a political figure
I don't think Tucker Carlson is wrong
about that does that make Trump's
behavior with stormy Daniels decent no
but let's not pretend the stormy Daniels
of the great hero of feminism then a
case chanc is very upset so Chang
tweeted out I'm not done yet
Tucker Carlson says that adult film
stars are indecent really how many adult
films do you think Tucker has watched in
his life in the thousands at least is he
claiming he has never watched any same
with ben shapiro who writes an anti porn
book please okay I have a few comments
on this first of all real weird the
chanc is
around thinking about how much porn I
watch very very weird I don't know what
he fantasized about in his spare time
but I'm a little creeped out I was just
sitting here doing nothing and suddenly
I'm being attacked by Chiang Kai Gor
with the suggestion that I watch porn I
did write a book about why pornography
is bad because pornography is bad like
it's it's not decent it's immoral hey
now I'm also confused by this idea that
Tucker Carlson is not allowed to say
that porn is indecent if he has ever
seen any porn at all this is like saying
that you think drug use is indecent if
but if you ever use drugs you can't say
that like I'm super confused by this
argument but it's an argument frequently
used on the left I'll also say that the
only pornography I need is the film of
chanc Uyghur mourning the election loss
like that is the only pornography I need
it's actually just shanks sitting there
weeping over the election loss the night
of the election because it's so it's so
good it's still hilarious so well done
shank really doing credit to to the
agenda of the left by talking about
Republicans watching pornography okay
speaking of other weird topic so LeBron
James who's now in Los Angeles because
he just moves teams with a certain
amount of regularity he is he's actually
done some good stuff LeBron James and
one things he's done is he's opened a
charter school basically and this
charter school is doing good work
they're actually bringing kids in
creating mentorship programs for them
preventing them from living in bad
situations oh that is wonderful
LeBron sees himself as a sort of quasi
political figure which means sometimes
he says smart stuff and sometimes he
says dumb stuff because everybody in
politics does LeBron yesterday was was
interviewed about all of this and he
said that President Trump is using
sports to divide us this is one of the
dumb things that the LeBron James is
saying I'm not somebody who thinks that
LeBron James has to shut up and dribble
you know LeBron James can say whatever
LeBron James wants to say I don't know
that he's a political expert in fact I'm
pretty sure that he's not but here's the
thing he said that that I think is
inherently silly what I noticed over the
last few months that he's kind of used
sport to kind of divide us and I and
that's something that I can't relate to
because I know that sports has never
been something that divide people has
always been something that brings
someone together okay here's the part
that's stupid I remember sports dividing
people long before President Trump was
actually in the Oval Office I remember
canceling my subscription
Sports Illustrated when they put Caitlyn
Jenner on the cover because I said this
is not a an athletically relevant person
has not been for 30 years but now I'm
going to get transgender propaganda in
my sports magazine in fact I remember
sports being so politicized that I was
threatened on national television and
grabbed by the back of the neck on
national television talking about sports
on national television before President
Trump was ever a candidate talking about
the Caitlyn Jenner issue where I
suggested that Caitlyn Jenner was in
fact a biological man because Caitlyn
Jenner happens to be a biological man
I'm old enough to remember when during
Ferguson a bunch of football players
running out on the field in the hands up
don't shoot pose which was completely
fictitious Michael Brown had never said
hands up don't shoot the idea that
politics and sports have been have been
politicized by President Trump is just
ignorance okay Colin Kaepernick was
kneeling on the field before Trump was
even running for president so none of
this makes any sense but I guess we're
now in the space where we can blame
President Trump for anything and for
everything and anything it doesn't it
doesn't wash but I guess it's a
convenient it's a convenient scapegoat
for all this stuff okay time for some
stuff I like him and a thing that I hate
so let's think I like it okay I think I
like the over the weekend I saw ant-man
and the wasp
so the original ant-man is a better
movie the sequel is also fun
it focuses a lot less on Paul Rudd which
is kind of unfortunate because Paul Rudd
is hysterically funny and they kind of
make him out to be
even more of a doofus in this one than
he is in the first one this one features
a lot of Evangeline Lilly it's a lot
more of at the wasp than it is ant-man
but that said the film is still fun the
highlight of the film honestly is
Michael Pena who is just an underrated
actor in every sense he he did the best
thing in the original ant-man if you
didn't see the original ant-man it is
actually one of my favorite Marvel
movies specifically because it is what
it purports to be which is a cotton
candy can't it's just it's it's a candy
apple of a movie it's just that there's
nothing of real weight or substance to
it but it has one of the best sight gags
ever and it also has this little riff
that Michael Pena does where he is
explaining how he got to where he is
it's it's really good in any case
ant-man in the wasp is definitely worth
seeing it's a lot of fun you'll enjoy it
it's not memorable but it is it is a
kick so here's a little bit of preview
[Music]
[Applause]
I do some dumb things the people I love
the most they pay the price
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
link to partner
okay so it is it's it's fun and if
you're just looking for something to
kind of entertain you over the weekend
there this is the first time in a while
there have been actually like three or
four movies in the theater that I
actually want to see so I haven't seen
the Mission Impossible movie yet I've
heard that it's fun and I've heard that
the action sequences are amazing and I
will let you know after I see it also
I've heard Incredibles 2 is really good
over the weekend I showed my daughter
Incredibles one because she's never
actually been to the theater so I want
to take her to see her first movie in
and I've heard that Incredibles 2 is a
good start
my sister shot with her two kids she
said was good so we'll go check that out
and then I will let you know okay time
for a thing that I hate and we will mix
it with the deconstruction of the
culture actually since it's a Tuesday so
Anne Hathaway is now sounding out about
about things that Anne Hathaway knows
like being black in America which is men
not a thing she knows about really she
hears here's what happened she railed
against white privilege and she
questioned how decent white people
really are after this 18 year old woman
named Niall Wilson died when she and her
sister Latifah 26 were attacked by white
male on a subway train in Oakland on
Sunday night July 22nd and I had died
from her injuries after she was stabbed
in the neck by a guy named John Lee Cal
and an Anne Hathway to put this out on
Instagram said the murder of Niall
Wilson may she rest in the power and
peace she was denied here is unspeakable
and must not be met with silence she's
not a hashtag she was a black woman and
she was murdered in cold blood by a
white man okay I agree that's that's an
awful awful terrible thing and I hope
that this guy is given the death penalty
there's white people including me
including you you must take into the
marrow of our privileged bones the truth
that all black people fear for their
lives daily in America and have done so
for generations given those Givens we
must ask our white selves how decent are
we really not in our intent but in our
actions in our lack of action peace and
prayers and justice for Naya and the
Wilson family not so I'm confused what
exactly this murder has to do with white
privilege really I am
I mean the guy was arrested he's going
to go to death row if if he is convicted
what exactly is the problem and half
when we can't aim it also the idea that
black people in America are fearing for
their lives every single day is such an
overgeneralization I can't even speak to
it I mean maybe there are some black
people in America who are fearful for
their lives every single day but we'd
have to ask whether that fear is
justified based on circumstance I'm sure
that there are some black people for
whom that is I'm sure there's some white
people for whom that is true as well
depending on where they are living the
levels of violence okay but
you know they're there a lot of black
people in the United States we're living
kind of middle-class lives and who are
not threatened with violence on a daily
basis I don't think they're walking
around thinking that they're in Fallujah
the this idea that simply because of
skin color in the United States you're
walking around in daily fear for your
life is such a misnomer and it really is
her talking down for for virtue
signaling points like Anne Hathaway
knows that she is going to be met with
all sorts of kudos from people on the
left for simply saying this stuff okay
so what does an half am I going to do
about any of this stuff really if Anne
Hathaway wants to make all these
problems better what is she gonna do
other than sound off on Instagram about
it she says don't just hashtag okay well
you just want an Instagram and posted
something now practically what are you
gonna do in Hathway about any of this
stuff at least LeBron James is trying to
do something at least LeBron is actually
creating schools to increase education
levels in the black community at least
LeBron James is trying to do something
publicly minded about this sort of stuff
the these actors and actresses who go
out and sound off on hashtags and then
they say we need to do more than
hashtags okay anytime you're ready we're
waiting and again that broad
overgeneralization about black people in
America fearing for their lives it's
hilarious to me that if I say that this
is a free country where effort is
rewarded that that is considered racist
and if Anne Hathway says all black
people are living in fear then that is
not considered a racial judgment so I
say something completely non racial and
it's considered racial and she says
something completely racial and it is
considered non racial because the left
approves of it pretty insane okay other
things that I hate today so Twitter has
now hired academics to monitor hate
speech which is very exciting that's
just what we need a bunch of leftist
academics determining what exactly is
hate speech according to the UK
Telegraph Twitter has hired academics
from institutions including Oxford
University to help it combat intolerant
discourse and monitor the health of the
social network the firm is working with
social psychology professor miles Hugh
stone and John Gallagher along with dr.
mark here ding from the University of
Amsterdam to study the spread of hate
speech the move is part of Twitter's aim
to create algorithms the better
distinguish between hate speech and
conversations that break the norms of
politeness I don't know why any of this
is necessary frankly if you don't want
to see hate speech on Twitter don't
subscribe to somebody's Twitter feed or
just mute somebody the nice thing about
Twitter is they have all of these
features you can use to not listen to
folks but I guess that we are not
allowed to point that out at any point
we just have to assume that we're too
stupid to actually gauge
of conversations that we wish to
participate in and so we have to have
these overlords these academic overlords
you tell us what's good and what's not
all this is is highly foolish and it
undercuts I think the claims of Twitter
to to a sort of neutrality that they
have not actually put into practice okay
we will be back here at tomorrow with
all of the latest i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018